shakespeare goethe schiller brecht circa
200 mal ist im vergangenen jahr der
faust auf deutschsprachigen bühnen zu
sehen gewesen
180 mal die räuber 170 mal die
dreigroschenoper im ökonomischen würde
man so etwas eine mangelwirtschaft ja
das theater der gegenwart leidet an
einem mangel einem mangel an
überraschungen entdeckung an
dramaturgischer und spiel planerischer
diversität stadt in den reichhaltigen
schatz kann man der dran geschichte nach
anziehenden aufregenden um treibenden
stoffen zu suchen inszenieren die
theater einfach immer nur mehr vom
gleichen was wir heute brauchen ist eine
spielplan änderung
ich bin eigentlich fern von ganz
modernen theaterstücken von ganz
modernen schriften
je aktueller desto besser und so und ich
habe dann angefangen die ersten sätze zu
lesen und darf man auch gott mir jetzt
ist das so ein text mehr zu alter
schrift wird ja sehr alt gesprochen oder
geschrieben und dann habe ich aber
einfach mal weiter gelesen die ersten 20
30 zeilen und so und ich war gefesselt
denn das was so toll es geht ja wirklich
um travestie ja und das tolle in diesem
stück ist also für mich ist es obwohl es
nie nicht in einem wort erwähnt wird für
mich ist es hoch pornographisch ich habe
mich darin auch selber erkannt und zwar
im folgenden teil ich kann euch sagen
als gabriel das erste mal 'nen frauen
kleid anziehen und ihr bester freund
total scharf auf sie wird und sie sagt
warum siehst du mich so an
irgendwie hör auf damit und er sagt ich
kann ich anders und so weil es gibt
keine frau die schöner ist als du und so
und da dachte ich mir um mein gott
kriegt jetzt gänsehaut guckt euch das an
weil das war bei mir auch so ich war
immer so ein ganz anderer günes
bürschlein in der schule und kaum zog
ich einmal frauenkleidern
war es um mich geschehen habe ich sofort
mit fünf schulkollegen und auch meinem
besten freund geschlafen das passt also
genau wie in diesem stück und deshalb
hat mich das total berührt also und man
muss sagen
dieser ganze inhalt obwohl nicht einmal
porno vorkommt oder für mich ist sehr
hoch pornographisch hoch sexuell ich
finde gleich am anfang in dieser alten
schrift da wird ja gar nicht von der
wird ja über dem prinz geredet der ja
der erziehungsberechtigte ist aber
alleine wie dieser prinz und sein
angestellter der gabriel erzählt dieser
lehrern wie die über den reden da ist
für mich schon alles voll mit sexualität
und pornografie ich wusste schon ganz am
anfang ich brauchte eigentlich gar nicht
zu ende lesen ich wusste genau worauf es
hinausläuft weil diese geschichte auch
so ähnlich meiner ist und man sieht dass
spielt den ganz anderen jahrhunderten
ist immer noch der kleine schleifen
natürlich sind diese elemente dieser
zwischen poesie und umsturz oszillieren
wind das was mich daran entzünden
interessieren würde und was ich auch
gerne ja in einer inszenierung in den
mittelpunkt stellen würde
mir schwebt da sowas vor zwischen pop
und kitsch und theorie
das große finale wäre so gabriel trägt
zu einem mischung aus militär uniform
und hochzeitskleid
es ist die szene wo sie schwebt die spox
erklärt wird so zu ihren flügeln sie
schwebt durch die bühne aber sie schwebt
da hier eine projektion von sowjetischen
traktorist innen und dazu läuft beyoncé
replays und der song wird zur hymne der
umverteilung
man muss es spiel über den
hintergedanken der vereinsamung alle
diese figuren in dem stück die sich
anfangs zu gesellschaftlichen
zusammenkünften wie kartenspiel wie fünf
uhr nachmittags treffen werden am
schluss monaten seien vollkommen
vereinsamt die hauptfigur wird
vielleicht in einem plattenbau in einer
einzimmerwohnung als single leben und
alles was 19 jahrhundert an ihr war
gutsbesitzer reichtum reichtum der
kulturellen entfaltung alters wird ihr
genommen ein stück was aus der bequemen
lebensart in die schafe heutige
einsamkeit führt
was für mich besonders ist also die
sprache ist so in dem stück das dass man
das gefühl hat es geht immer um die
größten emotionen wenn man was wollte
erst mal benutzen dies gibt und es immer
als alles extrem einen ich habe das
gefühl die figuren sind wie tiere die so
dass ganz archaische regeln leben wie
also regeln der natur auf offene art
also wenn eine frau verstoßen wird dann
dann wird ihr der dann wird sie
unfruchtbar gemacht und es geht viel
eigentlich um um sex und leidenschaft
wer mit wem schläft und das ist alles
sehr es hat was ihr animalisches und die
sprache extrem vom rhythmus etwas sehr
also nicht schwerfällig aber was
wichtiger ist ein sehr wichtiger und
muss in der sprache und zum sprechen
glaube ich nach ist extrem viel spaß
weil es so massiv ist und alles alle
sätze immer so riesiger also riesige
ansagen sind
die möglichkeit bietet eben gegenwärtig
zu sein und besondere gegenwart zu
schaffen und das besondere jedes
augenblicks spürbar zu machen und dann
begriffe helfen dann ist biologe helfen
dann nicht masken helfen da nicht allein
seien geständig sondern sinnlichkeit zu
erfahren kann ich mich jetzt schon höher
aber ihr aber so ist es auch das will
der satan apa
er will nicht vorgefertigte ihm
aufgedrückte rollen erfüllen berufe
ausbildung eine laufbahn ein
lebensvollzug umsetzen sondern er möchte
lieber ein glas wein trinken den euphrat
entlang gondeln mit seiner großen liebe
er möchte sich dessen gewahr werden dass
das leben doch eine kette eine kette von
augenblicken ist es ist zeit dieses
stück zu entdecken und
es ist ein stück des augenblicks
wenn ich das stück inszenieren würde
würde ich sie auf den humor gehen weil
das habe ich glaube ich noch nicht
erwähnt ist es eine irre lustiges stück
und es gibt ja unterschiedliche formen
von humor wir haben einen sehr zarten
nur den zwischenmenschlichen wenn es zum
beispiel die schöne eva sich über die
männer lustig mache die auf den hintern
stand dann haben wir aber den sehr
derben humor wenn die vereinsfahne
dieses anglervereins der da sich trifft
in diese gastwirtschaft geschmiert wird
und dann reiben sie diese fahne mit
benzin ein und dann richten sie in ihren
mehr die fahne stinkt aber das gibt sich
schon oder wenn im herold er eigentlich
die vereins trompete trompeten soll das
gesicht aus versehen aufgeschüttet und
er kann halt eben nicht mehr in die
trompete blasen
ich würde das alles komplett ausschlafen
von von zarten tönen bis extremer
slapstick und ich finde dafür brauchst
ein großen bühne und schauspielerin die
lust haben auf pass altus
ein alter mann und ein fremder sitzen
oder stehen vor einem einfamilienhaus
hell erleuchtet und warten darauf wann
der richtige moment ist der familie drin
im haus mitzuteilen dass ihre tochter
tot aufgefunden worden ist
das ist die handlung dieses einakters
was mich als cool grafen an dem stück
interessiert ist ganz klar der moment
des wartens was passiert im körper in
dem moment was passiert mit meiner
ganzen gestalt was passiert mit meinen
händen was mache ich ihm gegenüber zu
jemand anderem
wie verhält sich das das ist das erste
spannende daran das zweite ist die
unterschiedlichen ebenen die mailing mit
sich bringt in diesem drama das ist
einerseits ist es das haus dann sind es
die zwei personen davor
und dann gibt es natürlich noch die
beobachtung dass der der zuschauer
was fand ich toll in dem stück das einen
sofort anspringt ist dass man sich das
als eine riesensause vorstellt das ganze
ding und das ist ja etwas etwas
eigentlich so oft begegnet dass man das
schon beim lesen sich als was als was
lautes als was tisches vorstellt wo
selbst im zuschauerraum laut ist und man
würste ist ja so und das ist ein großer
ein großes fest der theatralität auch es
ja
und das ist das was mich so fasziniert
hat eigentlich schon sofort wenn ich das
als ich das stück aufgeschlagen habe man
schlägt ja immer stücke auf und dann
liest man diese personenregister als
erstes und wenn man das von else
lasker-schüler liest hat man namen wie
rosa die riesen dame die drei herren mit
den grauen zylindern
der gläserne amadeus die lange anna der
pendel frederik und ich finde schon in
dem moment tut sich durch die namen eine
ganz eigene welt auf also der der leser
ist schon sozusagen angeregt zu einer
fantasie und fragt sich wer könnte das
sein oder was könnte das sein
und das ist ja nicht so häufig so
dieser gedanke ok heimat flucht gewalt
vertreibung
ich brauche nord ich brauche im zentrum
ich will so also in dem punkt ist es so
zu sagen dass man diesen mittelpunkt
betont und ich hatte mal irgendwie so
ein uhr ort wollte ich eigentlich machen
ja sind und den ort schlechthin und dann
und dann gab es in dem stück diesen
diese stufe mit am ofen und im zweiten
bild ist es glaube ich darum und dem
dritten bild es ist der baum mit einer
bank und da kommt es irgendwie ja schon
so direkt zusammen nur dass man sagt das
ist so irgendwie geht es so um
vielleicht etwas wo man sich hinsetzen
kann oder was unseren punkt irgendwie
definiert und dann dachte ich ziehe das
in eine massive große architektur
der erste
warum dieses stück so auf mich radikal
bewirkt hat damals ist ist das ende
weil alle anderen die buch geschichten
die ich kannte enden immer damit dass
der rabbiner schafft den dieburg
auszutreiben und dann bleibt das mädchen
geheilt wenn etwas geschwächt zurück und
alle sind glücklich und hier sagt das
mädchen ja auch gar nicht die
austreibung ich kümmere mich selber um
die sache und es ist für die zeit
ziemlich kugel man merkt dass diese
geschichte einfach mit einigen
umwandlungen immer wieder überlebt hat
immer wieder weitergeleitet wurde so
dass ich das gefühl habe die geschichte
ist immer noch heute sehr relevant und
damals fing ich an auch über meinen
ersten roman nachzudenken also ich hab
lange orthografisch bestehen aber wollte
immer fiktionen schreiben und ich habe
mich ziemlich früh entschlossen dass
wenn ich einen roman also im ersten
roman irgendwann schreibe dass dieser
roman auf eine art und weise mit dieser
tradition sich auseinandersetzen muss
und es ist tatsächlich so geworden
das heißt ich habe das gefühl dass wir
nicht diesen druck nicht entdeckt hätte
hätte ich mein roman jetzt nicht gehabt
marina zwar nimmt einfach den untergang
der alten welt am beispiel von casanova
zum anlass um darüber nachzudenken was
verschwindet was unwiederbringlich
verschwindet und wie es vielleicht nur
durch die dichtung gerettet erhalten und
überliefert werden kann
die figur des casanova ist zunächst eine
ein gerücht nämlich wenn das gesinde
über ihn spricht dass der erste akt der
in der küche statt findet auf schloss
dux dieses gerücht dass hier ein
verrückter älterer herr noch im hause
sei der kostümiert ist über den der
selbst schon aus der zeit gefallen ist
setzt sich fort im zweiten akt wo die
hofgesellschaft die quasi jetzt schon
die neue zeit bisschen repräsentiert
also sich über die traditionen des 18
jahrhunderts ich schon lustig zu machen
beginnen wenn dieses jahrhundert ende
die haben in dieser nacht und in diesem
zweiten akt tritt nun eingeladen von
fürst linie casanova selbst auf hoch
kostümiert wie ein fast wie ein clown
ich glaube dass das theater einen großen
magen hat wie es ein großes gehirn hat
das theater ist so ich oder ich halte es
für so unverwüstlich dass es die
unterschiedlichsten möglichkeiten in
sich sozusagen verdient aufnehmen kann
und sie wieder ausspucken kann ein
wesentlicher großer teil des theaters
wie ich es mir vorstelle ist in der tat
das literarische theater mein herz ist
aber durchaus offen auch für andere
formen des theaters ich bin auch keiner
von denen wie die zeitung für die ich
mich gerade äußere es in den letzten
jahren und
möglicherweise darüber hinaus doch immer
wieder geradezu vehement fordert dass
man doch die roman bearbeitung und die
autorisierten filme reduzieren möge ich
finde das nicht ein guter theater abend
ist ein guter theater abend ist ein
guter theater abend woraus er sich
irgendwann mal gespeist hat und worauf
er entstanden ist ist mir erst mal
wurscht